in eukaryotes the transcription takes
place inside the nucleus if we look into
this process we would understand the
eukaryotic RNA polymerase to move along
in a 5 prime to 3 prime direction along
DNA and using a template strand it
transcribes the mRNA the mRNA which is
now hanging out of the RNA polymerase
would be eventually treated by several
enzymes such as alternative splicing
enzymes capping enzymes etc and would be
further processed before it could have
could even finish the translation
transcription now several enzymes such
as methyl transferases triphosphate a's
guanylyltransferase etc form our five
prime cap and ultimately the mRNA is now
matured after alternative splicing
capping and polyadenylation
however this mRNA which we are calling
at a mature mRNA which has a cap at five
prime a polyadenylation tail at the
three prime entire sequence of this RNA
is not coding for a protein it turns out
let's say 70% of the sequences coding
for a protein and R is 30% the sequences
do not code for a protein rather these
sequences are regulatory elements these
are known as untranslated region because
they are not detected by the ribosomes
they are present in both Phi prime and
the three prime direction and they are
named as Phi Prime and three prime UTR
respectively now ribosomes bind to the
start codon at that coding region and
move along the coding region to
transcribe the protein of interest but
the untranslated regions are not bound
to ribosomes then what does these
untranslated region bind to and what are
the function
of these untranslated region why do they
even exist all of these questions need
to be answered and in this video we
would learn about the functions that
untranslated region play in terms of
translation regulation or regulation of
gene expression so first of all these on
translation untranslated regions both in
the 5 prime or 3 prime direction can
bind to several proteins which might aid
the nuclear export of the mRNA the mRNA
can only be translated and for the
processing can be done when it is out of
the nucleus and in this export process
several UT are binding proteins can
really help and help the mRNAs to be
exported not only that you TR can
regulate translational efficiency and in
a moment we would understand how does
that happen so let's say this is the
mature mRNA in case of eukaryotes the
the small subunit of the ribosome binds
to the five prime cap followed by
several initiation factors and then this
sort of scan where is the start codon
and then a particular tRNA which is the
initiator trna binds followed by
assembly of the large subunit and
thereby the translation initiation takes
place right imagine at the five prime
end there is the untranslated region
which has repetitive sequences and due
to that a loop sequence is produced as a
result this particular small subunit of
the ribosome and the initiation factors
would have a hard time moving towards
the start codon right or finding the
start codon this is how they can
possibly regulate the rate of
translation in this case the movement of
the small subunit of the ribosome would
be much slower right and that is how
translation could be regulated not only
the regulation of translation but these
utr can regulate the stability of the
mRNA and really regulate the rate at
which the mRNA code decay how does that
happen now
RNA degradation takes place via several
enzymes several exonucleases normally
these exonucleases cannot attack the RNA
because there is a five-prime crap but
there are crap removal enzymes which
removed the cap after several run rounds
of translation and eventually the RNA is
degraded but let's say in a uto region
there are several associated protein
complexes which might associate which
would prevent these exonucleases to
attack the RNA and degrade it quickly
that means the RNA would be stabilized
and stay there for longer so clearly you
can understand the amount of time the
RNA is alive is more and it could
possibly give rise to more number or
more rounds of translation right
definitely the translation round would
increase the level of protein produced
from that mRNA this is how the protein
concentrations can be multi modulated
and all of these can be regulated by
that particular sister eulah tree
element right which is present in the
C's in terms of the coding region now
this really enhance the stability of the
mRNA now not only these cases but not
these untranslated regions especially
three prime UTR could also work like a
docking site for micro rna's micro rna's
gets processed and bind to the three
prime UTR followed by binding of a big
complex which can eventually translate
regulate translation or aid in the decay
of the mRNA so micro RNA mediated
regulation is an important function of
the three prime UTR and many of the
genes which are regulated in development
and disease are regulated by these micro
rnas at its three prime UTR
not only that all of that we discussed
apart from that these utr can actually
regulate the subcellular
location of the mrn imagine a neuron
how does neuron decide that how to
localize its mRNA in the synapses or say
it's in the mitochondria so they really
regulate the localization of the mRNA by
the utr binding proteins which aid in
their transport to specific sub cellular
localization I hope in this particular
video we are able to clarify why
untranslated regions are important
coming to the sequence feature the five
prime UTR and three prime UTR both
doesn't have the same length phi prime
utrs are shorter than the three prime
UTR generally phi prime utrs are 100 to
200 nucleotides whereas in contrast the
three by mu TR are more than 800
nucleotides the TC contents also differ
between these two type of utrs
60 % GC contents are generally found in
phi prime UTR whereas 45% for the three
prime UTR all these point of differences
lead to different regimes of regulation
of translation or RNA stability
altogether we learn in this video that
you TR split diverse role to regulate
the central dogma processes and mostly
regulate the translation rate and mRNA
stability so I hope this short video was
helpful if you liked this video give it
a thumbs up don't forget to Like share
and subscribe and do let me know in the
comment how do you like my videos but
there would be a video on this
untranslated region which would be lot
more details ok
so stay tuned